welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and moon knight episode 3 introduced the
mcu's first roofing of the gods outside
of asgard to the egyptian ineads council
of the gods but what was really
interesting to note here is that only
five of the available nine gods of the
council even bothered to show up i mean
what the hell man was moving the
freaking moon in front of the sun not
enough to get four missing lazy avatars
out of bed to vote on the potential fate
of the earth's moon god can't you well
what if i told you that with thor love
and thunder's gore the god butcher
coming on the scene real soon that these
missing guys in the council could have
been butchered
a high accusation i know but let's
speculate on how this could be the case
my nerd babies but before i continue
head up to rockstarsmerch.com so that
you can get a new moon night inspired
shirt from our latest obsession line of
shirts and the design is super cool so
please head up to rockstarsmerch.com so
you can get this shirt now when mark's
trial and the great pyramid of giza's
glamorously godly conference room first
begins hathor the egyptian goddess of
love and music calls attendance
in attendance
horus
he sees
defnut osiris
and hattor
to hear the account of conscience
a thor osiris tefnut isis and horus i
thought this was a great pyramid of giza
not an opening day morbius screening
got him but here's the thing the mcu
version of the egyptian council of the
gods is a lot different than the real
world inead which is comprised of adam
the god of the sun and creation shu the
god of the air tefnut the goddess of
moisture and rainfall geb the god of the
earth nut the goddess of the stars
osiris the god of the underworld isis
the goddess of healing and magic
nephthys the goddess of night and set
the god of chaos but in the mcu the
idiot includes a thor and horus so it's
impossible to really tell who exactly is
missing from this lineup however from
previous episodes of moon night we get
to see hints as to who could be on the
ini ad in the mcu mainly through that
museum poster that steve points out to
his boss and through that book on the
iniad that steve grant reads to try to
keep himself awake because there we see
that osiris horus isis adam tefnut shu
hathor and geb make the cut in the mcu
but what's important to note here on
this page that steve branch is reading
is this event referred to as the great
rift god's turn away from man which is
of course episode one's way of teasing
episodes three's revelation that the
egyptian gods of earth left humanity
after they felt humanity abandoned
worship of them so this being said with
thor love and thunder confirming that
the gods of the mcu universe have a
serial killer hunting them down in the
form of christian bales gore the god
butcher these empty seats could be
marvel studio's way of teasing the
cosmic carnage to come by implying that
these four empty seats three of which
presumably belong to the gods adam gep
and shu are empty because they done got
gutted by a grey-faced gore with some
god grievances specifically the
grievances of the gods abandoning
mortals when they need the most
something that even konchu himself
chastises the egyptian board of
directors about when konchu accuses them
of trading in their compassion to live
in opulence in the overvoid i was
banished for not abandoning humanity
unlike the rest of you
we have not abandoned humanity
they abandoned us we simply trust our
avatars to carry out our purposes
without calling undue attention to
ourselves not like some of us avatars
are not enough
we need the might of gods
return from the opulence of the overvoid
before you lose this realm with the
overvoid of course being marvel's name
for the celestial heliopolis the
extra-dimensional hangout spot of a home
that all the gods who don't want to get
their white nikes dirty helping a human
in need live in you know just watching
mortal suffer like those creepy rich
vips from squid game because in the
comics gore becomes a god butcher mainly
because he gets super pissed when he
discovers the gods actually existed the
entire time everybody he loved and cared
about including his wife and child died
from horrible conditions on his home
planet like literally a good guy god
fighting an evil god named no who ends
up being the father of all the symbiotes
really really bad guy crash in front of
gore and gore is like ah gods exist
what were you doing up there all this
time my wife and children are dead and
then decided to use null sword all black
the necro sword to kill the good guy god
in his anger and rage starting his new
lifelong mission of butchering all the
gods of the universe who view the
suffering of mortals to be above their
care which is you know i sort of get
where he's coming from but you know
murder is never the answer and i'm sure
mcu gore the god butcher is going to be
just as pissed as his comic book
counterpart especially considering that
the eternals film revealed to us that
every single planet in the mcu universe
that houses sentient life are actually
just eggs to birth celestials and that
the eternals have been spending
countless eons helping the celestials
protect life in the universe just for
the sake of increasing their own ranks
something that absolutely could not
happen without the acknowledgement and
consent of the supposedly almighty
benevolent gods i mean odin was the
freaking all father in charge of the
protection of all nine realms after all
who who possessed the ultimate peeping
tom in heimdall who could actually see
all 10 million souls of everyone in the
universe that wasn't a dark elf or um
you know sometimes the frost giants kind
of weird isn't that
but that's a story for another day the
gods cannot claim ignorance towards
these incessant acts of genocide that
have been happening for billions of
years especially when we as the audience
know just how well they've been living
in asgard just enjoying the spoils and
benefits of odin and hella's long and
bloody campaign to bring the nine realms
under their reign by force that they
were living too good and with gore on
the loose this could explain why the mcu
inian has a lineup that is drastically
different to the real life and even the
comics in the ad like this iniat council
may have had to switch up the gods which
appeared on the council as their numbers
continue to thin or maybe just maybe
there are some gods in hiding who are
too scared to show their faces or even
their avatars faces for fear of getting
got by gore but hey speaking of this
great rift event from steven's library
book though it seems to be only
referring to the egyptian gods as this
is an egyptian god book the great rift
of gods turning away from man could have
actually been a global or even universal
decision for all the gods like the one
that was made in the comics in thor
number 300 when all the gods from all
the different religions all teamed up to
jump the celestials then the celestials
were like we're not doing that and they
threatened to destroy every single one
of earth's pantheons if the gods ever
ever interfered with their plans for
humanity again like they literally
threatened to burn asgard down they're
like hey we'll do it we'll do it and we
won't even think about it so though it
may seem like they were being kind of
harsh on konchu for messing with the
moon in the sky they might have been
quick to imprison him because they
feared the wrath of the celestials and
also possibly because kanchu just makes
too much noise with his you know also
always walking around earth and having
an avatar that kicks people's butts on
earth and they're all trying to stay off
of gore's radar completely because you
gotta remember when you're a god there
isn't much that can kill you so when
these gods find out that they're not
actually on the top of the food chain
because predators like gore the god
butcher and entities like airshim the
judge and the rest of the celestials
exist probably gonna want to hide with
your homies in the overvoid to avoid
being unemployed by an annoyed
anthropoid enjoying his all-black murder
toy from the void because you know you
kind of don't have a choice but that is
how i think moon knight episode 3 teases
the coming of gore the god butcher in
thor love and thunder but what do you
guys think do you guys think there's
another reason why those four seats
could have been empty let us know in the
comment section below but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] but most importantly follow
new rockstars wherever we are on social
media and when you do make sure you hit
that bell so you get notifications every
time we upload a video and again please
do not forget to pick up our latest
obsession moon night shirt because it's
not gonna last forever and the design is
literally my favorite shirt design that
i've seen ever since i've been here so
buy that before it runs out asap but
again thank you guys so much for
watching this video i love you guys so
much so so much i'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you